all right let's see how we did if you
checked record ID weather condition ID
minimum temperature wind speed humidity
maximum temperature date weather
direction and pressure you've got this
right now technically one could have
included either date or time as time
includes date month doesn't really make
any sense here but since we're really
displaying the date it makes sense for
the database to actually replicate
what's on the display as much as
possible unit should be stored in a
separate table for preferences there's
no reason to store things we aren't
displaying such as you know rainfall or
average temperature and besides we
cannot get these from the open weather
map API we do need weather condition ID
since we use this to both display the
forecast and determine the image to
display and finally while it's not
displayed in our UI we need an ID column
to uniquely identify each row as
discussed it's required for all SQLite
database tables that are going to be
displayed in Android listviews